foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] what up honey yeah I can't take
a pic right now but uh oh no no Danny
from work Danny yeah yeah what are you
doing here do you live in Bushwick me no
[ __ ] no oh no I never live here
uh no I'm supposed to be going to uh
there
matcha baby of course my plug lives here
so
two birds one stone I smoke marijuana
like all the time you ever see one of
these
hmm
other side
oh
okay all right
oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
yo calling
hey yo shorty what up I love your videos
Man Costa Rica looks sick let's go baby
stay up boss all right what up you good
it's so cool
oh yeah I got I got a bunch that's just
one
so like what are you
like add to gravity what are you I'm a
writer started in the photo department
but I'm transitioning and then I'm
looking to like develop my work more by
like
maybe like going on one of those writer
Retreats or something oh you want to
retreat what going on retreat
oh I just got invited to a retreat
I'm sure he's actually uh coming up next
week
going to Paris for it
[ __ ]
that's dope hey get pigs I'm gonna get
lots of pics yeah I'll throw them all up
on the ground by the way this was laced
with like mad wax so your tolerance must
be odious [ __ ]
damn Ma
good luck in Paris Jenny good to meet
you Danny what's up my name is Danny
no it's calling
I'll see you at work or I guess I won't
[Laughter]
[ __ ] me
[Music]